you can get in trouble for saying almost
anything these days on a college campus
depending on what the administrators
wins everyone could be offended by
something
hey it's Kennedy four reason TV at
Freedom Fest sitting down with Greg
Luciana he's the president of the
foundation of individual rights and
education fire so what's hot in fire
right now um we always have more
ridiculous cases than I can usually
explain in a five-minute session but one
the one that is going on right now that
we find kind of amazing is free speech
zones have really made a comeback and
what free speech zones are on campus are
tiny little areas where administrators
say these are the only places you can
protest these are the only places you
can hand out flyers and these are things
we've been fighting since day one and
they've really kind of come back into
fashion this year for some reason and we
have a case at University of Cincinnati
public College they were trying to tell
young Americans for liberty that they
had to give 10 days advance notice to
use a free speech zone that was point 1
percent of the entire campus and if they
tried to hand out materials these are
students attending this school that they
would be arrested for trespass you can
get in trouble for saying almost
anything these days on a college campus
depending on what the administrators
wins everyone can be offended by
something oh yeah
and sometimes I'm not even offended this
year there's a major theme I feel like
it's just this very pure kind of like
don't you dare criticize me kind of like
parental kind of thing going on that's
pretty audacious yes I think so too and
you have written a book I have that
touches on this very subject tell us
about it it's called unlearning liberty
and the second title is a campus
censorship and the end of American
debate and what I'm trying to be I'm
trying to make the point that after 11
years of looking at college censorship
that this is starting to have a negative
effect on the way our country talks
within itself I think it harms our
ability and inclination to debate if the
one institution that's supposed to be
making us deeper more honest harder
thinkers is actually saying and if you
disagree kind of shut up what will
change it and how do you change it I
think there's a there's some cultural
changes that are actually fairly easy to
implement another some structural
changes that need to happen the cultural
change is just we have to make the idea
of talk to the smart person you disagree
with see
them out if we can if that actually
becomes an intellectual habit among
educated people that would solve so many
problems until are supposed to do aren't
they supposed to challenge one on the
others ideas in order to make them
better that's totally what they're
supposed to do but that is just not
possible if you can get in trouble for
having the wrong opinion on campus
because I think sometimes some of these
administrators who were particularly
fond of speech codes think that what
happens if you say don't say anything
offensive don't say anything
controversial because you can get in
trouble they think that those ideas are
just going to go away but what does up
happening is people just end up talking
to people they already agree with yeah
and instead of ameliorating group
polarization on our universities we're
supercharging yeah and and what can
students who are watching this right now
who are in school who are feeling the
backlash and the persecution for their
ideas what can they do well first go to
the fire org and we have the top 400
schools in the country we have all their
speech codes on there and if your
university has a speech code it's a
great fight that you can win to to
organize students against it or free
speech zone for example you can really
get students from all across the
political spectrum to fight that so it's
a great way to get people talking and
thinking about freedom of speech and
that being said sixty-five percent of
the florida colleges that we that we
look that we analyze on have red light
speech codes and this is just a complete
scandal that not enough people are
noaa's out there but it's a great
opportunity the same time to make free
speech an important issue on campus
because this generation has taken Tanna
takes it for granted that there'll be
all of these restrictions on speech but
it's unconstitutional in a public campus
and on a private campus most private
campuses claim to value freedom of
speech and if they do you can't freedom
of speech to get people to attend their
school and then say yeah but you can't
really upset anybody with with your
op-ed all right well thank you for
educating everybody on this subject
about education Greg
you